مهله جديده مدتها خمسه ايام لاعطي مجال
لحسم الخلافات التي ظهرت بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع قبل توقيع
الاتفاق السياسي النهائي في السادس من
ابريل الحالي دمج قوات الدعم السريع في
الجيش نقطه الخلاف الابرز بين الجانبين
الناطق باسم العمليه السياسيه خالد عمر
قال ان مساله الدمج تجري وفق مرجعيات متفق
عليها صرات الاطراف الحاضر بالاكبار
العسكريه
ان تكثف من جهدها لحل هذه القضايا الفنيه
العالقه خلال الفتره من الليله وحتى يوم
السادس من ابريل واذا اكتملت يتم التوقيع
خلال اليوم السادس من ابريل هذا هو القرار
الذي اتخذ الخلافات بين الجيش والدعم
السريع ترتكز حول المده الزمنيه للدمج يرى
الجيش ان ذلك ينبغي ان يكون خلال الفتره
الانتقاليه بينما تقترح قوات الدعم السريع
اضعاف المده التي تحدث عنها الجيش
وترى تلك القوات ضروره اجراء اصلاحات
شامله للاجهزه الامنيه قبل دمجها بينما
يرى الجيش ان قضيه الاصلاح شان يخص القوات
المسلحه معضله الاساسيه كيف سيتم استيعاب
وتسريح ونزع بعض الجنود الذين يتبعون
لقوات الدعم السري لان هذه القوات
عشائريه وتحالفاتها تحالفات اقليميه مما
يصعب هذا الامر وفي الوقت الذي تتسارع فيه
الخطى لمعالجه قضيه دمج قوات الدعم السريع
تكثف لجنه الوسطاء اتصالاتها لاقناع
الرافدين بالانضمام الى العمليه السياسيه
لكنها جهود لم تؤتي اكلها حتى الان نحن هو
النصل الى اتفاق سياسي جديد
وهذا الاتفاق هو الذي يؤدي الى انحاء هذه
الازمه السياسيه والوصول الى التوافق
المعقول الذي يضمن لنا الاستقرار السياسي
والاقتصادي والامني في البلاد وقد اغلقها
منسوبون الى المجلس الاعلى للنظرات البيئه
الطريق القوميه الرابطه بين مدينه
بورسودان الخرطوم لمده يوم واحد عند نقطه
وقاموا باشعال الاطارات ووضع الحواجز
الترابيه احتياجا على سير العمليه
السياسيه
مهله جديده لتوقيع الاتفاق السياسي
النهائي وحل ازمه مستعصيه بين الجيش وقوات
الدعم السريع ازمه ذات تشعبات سياسيه باتت
تشكل هاجسا لدى كثيرين ما يهدد العمليه
السياسيه برومتها الطاهره المرضي الجزيره
الخرطوم